what a moment in history gs-7 is coming
we don't know exactly one but it's
coming but it's coming
I'm Katie Kraus I'm Oscar Gracie and
we've created this insanity this board
this gorgeousness it's literally a
representation of our minds at this
point because we're losing it you're
losing it yes
so we're gonna run down everything we
know all the clues that we have maybe
possibly figurative or just made up in
our head which is also quite possible
probably the truth right now let's just
get right into it please yes starting
with this picture
that really started off the new
Instagram aesthetics sister snapped in
this photo honestly I mean gorgeous
Cinderella Mouse yes and then this is
when we started seeing a little bit of
change so this little photo of Meredith
all snuggled up a little perrito
seemingly matched the same color scheme
of this pose and this is when the sirens
went on this is when we were triggered
house down boots mm-hmm with her it
doesn't mean nothing when she does
something seven palm trees guys that
means something it means something as
she knew that we would lose our minds
trying to decode this photo a hundred
percent better we get this one we
thought we're looking for the seven
again mm-hmm seven stairs down but oh
wait a minute is this maybe possibly a
countdown because she's six stairs and
Katie what happened the next day when we
saw this photo of the fence
we had a conniption fit you guys we were
counting bricks trying to make sense is
there some sort of seven symbolism here
you guys I stood in to wear sunglasses
thinking there was a hidden message in
it I would thought I would see the
release day in her life days but wait
one two three four five holes in the
gate the countdown is on that's when we
snapped truly then she snapped back oh
yeah yeah with Olivia yeah because the
next day we didn't get a post and she
threw us all off for like oh maybe well
we're just insane
maybe we're just crazy and then she came
through with Miss detective Olivia
Benson just hanging on the bed caption
she just read all the theories so our
good mom obviously was just making fun
of us at that point she was really
pulling our wigs but still we think
something is happening because then
we get this beautiful elk cover which
still is in theme with me aesthetics she
doesn't just do covers unless something
is happening pops new power the music
issue
she takes control it's happening you
know it's happening and the pinks and
yellows perfectly aligning with this
gradient and the countdown is still on
you guys because this doesn't throw
anything off this all still seemingly
leads up to the end of the countdown
which is marked in the reputation
calendar with a flower on March 2nd
let's sort of talk about all these
theories is this the album that was
supposed to come after 1989 before
reputation which is a solid conspiracy
theory in my book honestly I think so
too I mean who is this Taylor in the
back of that look what you made me do
video palm-tree clad taylor of who's
covering up the plane with reputation
the foxy spray-painting it means that
this plane was not meant for reputation
and music was meant for something else
and she got to cover it up and make it
into this era the theme of this hey the
color scheme is a graduation of 1989
right we had the Polaroids in the
pestel's no more vibrant saturated
gradients going on 100% still matching
up with the palm trees to this photo we
think there's like a coastal vibe yes we
think that's why she did the whole Lake
Ariel the mermaid thing which matches
the cloth to this jacket she wore in a
reputation promo it's a camera jacket
but we still see you sis
on the back 7 palm tree patches on the
reputation jacket nothing she does is on
act no the fact that this photo came out
so long ago this photo came out so long
ago she was already thinking about it so
to wrap up let's go through the players
really fast
okay Ryan Tedder is it a coincidence
that his Twitter header is palm trees no
because Ryan and Taylor have worked
together before Ryan loves working with
her I said a million nice things about
her Jack Antonoff he's been in the
studio that's a no-brainer no-brainer
they were great together Katy Perry this
one's a little dicey you know you see
the theories we see you but mm-hmm
max Martin
power 100% back with it yes and pops new
power they are pop power duo before we
wrap up album names you guys what are we
thinking I'm thinking maybe something
like paradise
maybe something more like bloom I think
bloom is a big possibility a hundred
percent
symphony of color that's the most
gorgeous thing I've heard of the
spectrum of it all the rainbow perhaps
yes we want to know what you guys think
though have we officially lost our minds
what do you think the new album is gonna
be called no we are all over social
media who talked about Taylor all the
time we want Taylor with you a hundred
percent
yeah I'm Katy I'm Oscar we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]